NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on nonlinear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In this lecture I'd like
to discuss with you
some example solutions.
In the last lectures, we
discussed quite a bit of
theory related to finite element
formulations and
numerical algorithms, and I
thought that you might like
now to share with me
some experiences
regarding example solutions.
The examples that I'd like to
discuss with you are first,
the analysis of a truss arch,
the snap-through analysis of a
truss arch.
Then the collapse analysis of
an elasto-plastic cylinder.
Then the large displacement
solution of a spherical shell.
Then we want to look at the
analysis of a cantilever, the
large displacement analysis
of a cantilever when that
structure is subjected
to pressure loading.
Once deformation independent
pressure loading, and once
deformation dependent loading.
And then we would like to look
at the analysis of a
diamond-shaped frame.
And finally, I'd like to discuss
with you the failure
and repair of a beam/cable
structure.
So let me know walk over here to
some view graphs which give
us the information regarding
all the analyses.
The first example you're looking
at is a simple truss
structure which is shown
here that is
subjected to a load r here.
Notice this is a two degree
of freedom system only.
Actually, if you use symmetry
conditions you would have a
one degree of freedom system.
Notice the dimension
l is equal to 10.
k, the stiffness, ea over
l, is given here.
You want to perform a
post-buckling analysis of the
structure using the automatic
load step incrementation
algorithm, and then perform a
linearized buckling analysis.
Notice that the two solution
algorithms that we are using
to perform these two analyses
were discussed in
the previous lecture.
I assume in this lecture that
you're quite familiar with
what I have been discussing,
particularly in the previous
two lectures.
Let us start then with the
post-buckling analysis.
Analytical solution to this
problem is given here, and
actually, this solution is also
given in the textbook.
So please refer to the textbook
for the derivation of
this equation.
The response can be plotted, and
here you see is a plot of
the load r as a function of
the displacement data.
Notice this, of course, is a
critical point, a limit point.
And the difficulty particularly
is to march up
here the solution algorithms,
march across that limit point,
and then down here, and
further up here.
The automatic load step
incrementation procedure that
we discussed was employed with
this starting displacement.
One data is, of course, equal to
1u, and we set it equal to
plus 0.1, and the solution
obtained is given here.
Notice this is a finite element
solution, which of
course is very close to the
analytical solution.
The solution details for load
step seven are given in this
table here.
Let's look at this table
now a bit closer.
At the beginning of that load
step we have for the
displacement, this value, and
for the load, that value.
As we iterate, i, of
course, increases.
We obtain this solution for
the displacement, this
solution here for the load, and
these are here, the actual
load applied, corresponding to
t plus delta t lambda i, in
other words.
These are the incremental
displacements, and these are
the incremental load.
Now, as we discussed in the
previous lecture, in the
algorithm using the constant
arc length, we see that the
displacement here increases.
The total displacement
increases, of course.
The total load here actually
decreases.
The incremental displacement
for this step, as
you can see, increases.
The incremental load
decreases.
And that gives us, of course,
this behavior that we talked
about, namely that the
displacement and load
increments lie on this arc.
That's why the constant
arc length algorithm.
Pictorially, for this load step
we can see the following.
Notice here is our equilibrium
configuration at which we are
starting with iteration.
Notice the final load increment
that we want to
obtain is given by lambda r.
Notice the final displacement
increment that we want to
obtain is u.
And we're iterating towards
this u, and towards that
lambda r, as shown
further here.
In the first iteration
we get lambda 1 of r,
and lambda and u1.
That gives us this point.
In the second iteration
we get that point.
In this third iteration
And after the completion of the
iteration, at convergence
we end up on that point.
Notice that if you take this
point here and connect it with
the iteration i point, you would
get an arc around here.
And that is, of course, a
constant arc length algorithm.
Also please, I should point out
here that we have broken
the scale as shown down here.
So we are starting here
already with 0.7
and here with 13.000.
The solution details for load
step here, load step eight,
are as follows.
We used, for this particular
load step, the increment of
external work algorithm.
The modified Newton iteration,
as well.
And these were the starting
values now.
And notice that we have
immediate convergence.
I pointed out in the previous
lecture that for a single
degree of freedom with the
constant increment of external
work algorithm, we will
have convergence
after the second iteration.
In other words, the effective
delta u2 is going to be 0.
And that is shown right here in
the table, and also in this
picture here.
Notice here is load
step seven.
The equilibrium point at which
we are starting off now, we
want to of course walk
along this red curve.
Notice in the first iteration we
come to this point c here.
i is equal to 1.
And then immediately we shoot
down in the second iteration
to the actual red curve.
So we immediately converge, as
pointed out in the earlier
lecture, and on the
earlier u graph.
The u displacement is equal to
u of 1 because delta u2 is
equal to zero.
Let us now go and perform
linearized buckling analysis
for the same problem to estimate
the collapse load for
the truss arch.
We talked about the algorithm
that we're using for this
linearized buckling analysis
in the previous lecture.
Here we have the actual load
displacement curve.
This is the collapse load that
we would like to estimate in
our linearized buckling
analysis.
Now, if we use delta t of r
1,000, our predictive collapse
load is 25,600.
Of course, our starting value,
our t minus data
tk is equal to 0k.
I'm now referring, in other
words, to the view graph that
we saw in the earlier lecture,
and the t minus delta t of k
there is equal to 0k.
The delta, the t of k is equal
to data t of k now.
And delta t of r corresponding
to delta t of k
is given right here.
Notice that this number is much
larger than the number
that we want to estimate.
The reason being that the
pre-buckling displacements are
not small in this
particular case.
And I pointed out in the earlier
lecture that that is
really necessary, the necessary
condition to obtain
good results, acceptable
results, in a linearized
buckling analysis.
It is not the case here,
and that's why we are
overestimating the buckling
load, the collapse load, by
quite a bit.
If we, however, increase our
delta t value such delta t of
r is 10,000, then you would
see that our predictive
collapse load is decreasing, and
gets closer to the value
that we want to obtain.
As we increase our delta t of
r value, and that means of
course that we are getting
closer and closer to the
collapse load by this value
here, we find that we are
getting, in our prediction for
the linearized buckling load,
closer and closer to the value
that we want to obtain.
These values here, by
the way, have been
given to three digits.
You notice that 15,000 certainly
is very close to
this value, but notice that the
delta t of r value is very
close to the buckling
load itself, to the
collapse load itself.
This is something
to keep in mind.
The basic conclusion here
is that the pre-bucking
displacements should be small in
the analysis in order to be
able to obtain good results.
By good I mean that the
linearized buckling load will
be close to the actual
collapse load of the structure.
Let's look at an extension
off this example.
And that extension is given
on this view graph.
Here we have still our truss
structure, but now we
introduce here this spring.
Let's called that
spring k star.
And this is the value that
we give to that spring.
If we trace out the load
displacement response, that
load displacement response
is shown here.
Load vertically.
Displacement horizontally.
And we notice that our stiffness
matrix is always
positive definite in
all of this region.
So we don't really have a
singular matrix, and we don't
have what we might call
a true collapse load.
The structure is stable
in some sense.
Of course when we talk about a
stable structure, we really
have to also define what
we mean by stability.
In a practical analysis you
might say, well, this
displacement is just too much,
and therefore I already
consider this structure
to be unstable at
this particular location.
You might want to say
that, depending
on your design criteria.
However, one thing to keep
in mind is that, in this
particular example,
we do not have a
single stiffness matrix.
The matrix stays positive all
the way as we march up on that
load displacement response.
Let's perform a linearized
buckling analysis of this
structure now.
And when we take delta t
of r equal to 10,000--
in other words, down here,
our delta t of r--
we get tau r as a collapse
load, 60,700.
And if you take delta t of r
40,000, we get tau r 44,100.
Notice that this is predicted
by the computer program.
However, we also know that there
is no true collapse load
in the sense of obtaining a
single stiffness matrix.
So, here we learn something
more from this example.
Namely that, in the linearized
buckling analysis we may
predict the collapse load, but
there may not actually be a
collapse load in the structure
response corresponding to a
single stiffness matrix.
Whether you really want to
accept this here as a collapse
load depends on your
design criteria.
Let's now look at another
example, the second example.
And in this example we want to
consider the analysis of a
cylinder that can undergo
enough elasto-plastic
conditions.
The material data of the
cylinder are given here.
The geometric data of the
Our goal is to determine the
limit load of the cylinder.
The finite element method we're
using here is shown on
this view graph.
Notice we have 8-node
elements here.
Four 8-node elements.
And in fact, if we look closely
at the response of the
cylinder, we can identify that
these middle nodes really are
not necessary, because the
response in the cylinder--
We assume the cylinder to
be infinitely long.
For that reason we have
introduced plane strain
conditions.
The response of the cylinder is
such that the same stress
condition is obtained
throughout the
lengths of the cylinder.
There is no variation in
stresses along the length of
the cylinder.
And for that reason we could
actually have analyzed the
structure with 6-noded
elements.
In other words, we could
have dispensed
with these nodes here.
The internal pressure is
shown here to which
the cylinder is subjected.
And once again we want to
predict the ultimate load of
this cylinder.
Since the displacements are
small, we use here an MNO
formulation.
In this load displacement, the
response calculation, if we
don't use the automatic load
step incrementation- the one
that we discussed in the
previous lecture--
the analyst has to prescribe a
load level, or a load curve,
prior to the analysis.
And here we have chosen
this load curve.
Notice time is plotted
along this axis.
Pressure is plotted
And notice also that the elastic
limit load is 7.42.
Therefore this kink here
is just above the
elastic limit load.
There's very little point in
using a lot of steps here,
because we know that an MNO
formulation will reduce to a
linear analysis until the
heave point is reached.
Or the elastic limit
load is reached.
So, we can go basically in one
step right up to the elastic
limit load, and then we take a
series of steps to trace out
the nonlinear response beyond
the elastic limit load.
The purpose of the analysis was
really to compare various
solution algorithms--
the full Newton method with line
searches, the full Newton
method without line searches,
the BFGS method, the modified
Newton method with line
searches, the modified Newton
method without line searches,
and the initial stress method.
Now please recall that all
of these techniques were
discussed in the previous
lecture, and I'd like to refer
you back to that lecture to read
up on this material if
you're not very familiar
with what I mean here.
The convergence criteria that we
are using for the solution
are given on this view graph.
Notice here our ETOL,
and here our RTOL.
We saw these formulas in the
previous lectures, and I don't
want to go now through
these formulas again.
The only point that I should
mention here is that this is a
value you have to select.
That is a value that
you have to select.
In the computer program that
we are using, the ADINA
program, of course, at default
values, which are really
working quite well over a
large range of nonlinear
problems, and those, of
course, are used very
frequently.
The RNORM here you
have to select.
And this is a reasonable number
when you compare it
with the total load applied
to the cylinder.
Notice that we're looking here
at one radian of the cylinder.
It's an axisymmetric analysis.
When these procedures are
used to calculate the
force-deflection curve, we find
that for p equal to 14,
none of these procedures
converges.
The response is shown here that
is calculated up to p
equals 13.5.
Of course, we have here drawn
a smooth curve through the
discrete solution points that
have been obtained.
If we compare now the different
solution techniques
in terms of their cost
effectiveness, we find that
normalizing to the full Newton
method solution time, we find
that the full Newton method with
line searches takes 1.2
times the time that is used
in the full Newton method.
The BFGS method has here 0.9.
The modified Newton method
with line searches 1.1.
The modified Newton
method 1.1.
And the initial stress
method 2.2.
Showing that the BFGS is just a
tiny bit more effective than
the full Newton method, hardly
worthwhile mentioning.
But we also see that the initial
stress method is twice
as expensive as virtually all
of the other methods.
Once again please refer back
to the previous lecture in
which I have been discussing
these various solution
techniques.
If we use the automatic load
step instrumentation we do not
need to specify a load
function anymore.
We discussed that earlier.
And the softening in the
force-deflection curve is
automatically taken
into account.
With this technique, these are
the tolerances that we used.
Default tolerances
in ADINA here.
And this is the same RNORM
value that we used in the
earlier analysis.
Now the displacement response
is calculated as shown here.
The p versus displacement
curve follows this path.
And notice that the computed
limit load is
really p equals 13.8.
In the earlier analysis we
could not go beyond 13.5.
In other words, for a value of
p equals 14 we did not reach
convergence.
We did not reach convergence
because the
limit load is 13.8.
And this is the difficulty
that I referred to at the
start of last lecture.
You see, if you use the earlier
solution algorithms,
you have to very slowly this
restarting, or a very
judicious choice of a load
function, get yourself closer
and closer to the limit load.
And that can be time
consuming.
That means it also consumes
quite a bit of cost.
Computer cost as well as
cost of your time.
And therefore, it is so much
more convenient to use an
automatic solution algorithm,
that means you don't need to
specify a load function, that's
simply marches up here
and gives you is the actual
collapse load quite easily, as
shown here.
Notice an interesting point is
that we actually march along
this plateau when we use this
automatic solution algorithm.
Let's look now at the
next example.
And this pertains to the
solution of a spherical shell.
Here we have a plan
view of the shell.
The edges are clamped.
And here we have a side
view of the shell.
The shell is subjected to a
concentrated load at its apex.
And we will increase that load,
as shown later on, to a
very large value, so that this
shell, schematically shown
here once again, will undergo
large displacements here.
In fact, this point here will
move, as my pointer shows
here, all the way down
to this level.
Notice that this
distance here--
and let me show it a
little bit clearer
here on the view graph--
is equal to .0859 inches.
Here you see the other geometric
data of the shell,
and here you see the
material data.
We perform an axisymmetric
analysis of this shell.
The finite element mesh is
shown in this view graph.
Here we have the original mesh
subjected to the load.
Notice that since we're looking
at an axisymmetric
analysis, and since we are using
ADINA, we apply here a
load of p, the total load
divided by 2 pi, because we
only look at one radian of
the total structure.
This 2 pi comes from the fact
that we are only analyzing one
radian of the structure.
The deformed configuration for
p equal 200 pounds is shown
here in red.
Notice we undergo large
displacements here, and that
is also shown on the next view
graph, which gives the force
deflection curve obtained with
this finite element mesh.
And that force deflection
curve is shown here.
The linear analysis would
predict this response.
Of course, way off the actual
response when the
displacements become large.
For this problem, the maximum
load is 100 pounds, and we can
apply that maximum load in one
load step, or in a sequence of
load steps.
If we apply the full load in 10
equal steps, we find that
the full Newton method
with line
searchers works very nicely.
The full Newton without line
searches, in fact, is even
more effective.
Notice the BFGS method, the
modified Newton method with
line searches and without
line searches.
These three methods
did not work.
Of course, 10 steps to full
load with these very large
displacements means really
using a very coarse load
incrementation, or using, in
other words, a very small
number of load steps.
These were 10 equal load steps,
I should also say.
If we apply the full load in 50
equal steps, we find that
the full Newton method
with line searches
is still most effective.
And these four methods
here converge.
They are not quite as effective
as the full Newton
method, but the modified Newton
method without line
searches does not
even converge.
You would have to use many
more steps to make the
modified Newton method without
line searches also converge.
Here, the BFGS method compares
quite favorably with these
methods here.
The convergence criteria
employed for this problem are
shown here.
Notice ETOL is given here
as 0.001 default
in the ADINA program.
We used a maximum number of
iterations that we're
permitted, which
is very large.
Very large in this
particular case.
We, of course, may also perform
the analysis using the
automatic load stepping
algorithm.
Here we use as this tolerance
ETOL, and RTOL this tolerance.
Our norm is shown here.
These are once again
default tolerances
in the ADINA program.
The response that we calculate
is shown on this view graph.
Here, the applied
load once again.
Displacement at the apex.
And this is the response
calculated.
Using as the initial
displacement 0.001 inches.
You get the solid curve.
And using as initial
displacement 0.01 inches, we
get these points here.
Notice, or recall please, that
when we use the automatic load
stepping algorithm, we start
off that algorithm by
specifying the displacement
for the first
load step at one node.
And these are the values that
I'm talking about here.
As a next example, I'd like to
look with you at the analysis
of the cantilever under
pressure loading.
Here we have the cantilever.
This is the pressure
loading applied.
Notice it's quite a long
cantilever, when
measured on the gaps.
Here are the material data.
We analyze this problem using
plane strain situation, and we
want to perform the analysis for
p equal to 1 megapascal.
The interesting point here is
to perform the analysis once
with a deformation-independent
loading, p the vertical and
remaining vertical, throughout
the whole analysis, and once
with a deformation-dependent
loading assumption, in which
the pressure loading remains
perpendicular to the
mid-surface of the cantilever.
I think you can appreciate
that if you have this
situation, the deformations
will be larger.
Well, we performed both of these
analyses, and once again
the purpose here was really to
contrast the assumption of
deformation-independent loading
with the assumption of
deformation-dependent loading.
The finite element model that
we used consisted of 25
two-dimensional 8-node elements,
one layer through
the thickness, and they
were evenly spaced.
And here we list the
solution details.
We used the full Newton method
without line searches.
And the convergence tolerance
is shown here.
I should also add that we used
10 steps for the total load
that we wanted to reach.
10 equal steps.
The force deflection curve is
shown on this view graph.
For small deflections, down
here, there's basically no
difference with respect
to the assumption of
deformation-dependent
loading or
deformation-independent loading.
However, as the displacements
become larger, the two curves
part from each other and,
as expected, the
deformation-dependent loading
gives larger displacements.
I should add here, if you look
back at what we discussed in
our earlier lectures, I should
add that regarding the
solution for the
deformation-dependent loading
case, we used a stiffness matrix
that is symmetric.
The same stiffness matrix, as a
matter of fact, that we are
usually using when
we are analyzing
deformation-independent
loading.
The deformation dependency of
the loading was only taken
into account by updating the
right hand side load vector t
plus delta t of r.
In our earlier discussions, we
very largely assumed that t
plus delta t of r is constant,
and prescribed by the analyst.
But I also pointed out in the
earlier lectures that, if we
have deformation-dependent
loading, you would have a t
plus delta t of r, superscript
i minus one, where that i
minus 1 then refers to the
configuration corresponding to
the i at the end of i minus
first iteration.
So, in this particular solution,
when we dealt with
the deformation-dependent
loading, we kept this as the
matrix difference
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
on the left hand side, but we
updated the load vector t plus
delta t of r in the notation
that we used in our earlier
lectures for the configuration,
and for the
iteration, that we actually
are dealing with.
And when we did so, we found
that to obtain this total
curve here, to obtain this total
curve, we needed about
20% more solution time than for
attaining this curve here.
So, taking into account the
deformation-dependency of the
loading in this particular
example just meant 20% more
solution time with the
computer program.
Here on the next view graph now,
we show pictorially how
the cantilever has deformed.
Here is the original mesh.
And here is the deformed
mesh when we use the
deformation-independent loading
assumption, and here
is the deformed mesh when we
use a deformation-dependent
loading assumption.
Notice, of course, that the
deformations are larger when
we have assumed that
the loading
is deformation dependent.
Let us now look at
the next example.
And in this example
we consider a
diamond-shaped frame.
That frame is shown here.
Notice we have a frictionless
hinge up there and down here.
We have a rigid weld
here and over here.
Notice that the frame is pushed
down with a load p
here, and is pushed up here.
Of course, as deformations of
the frame would be symmetric
about this line here, notice
that the beam cross section is
one inch by one inch, and
here are the material
data for the beam.
An elastic large displacement
analysis is
what we want to perform.
We use twenty 3-node isobeam
elements to model
the complete frame.
We will talk about the
isoparametic, or isobeam
elements later on in
a later lecture.
Notice this is here 15 inches,
and so is that.
The deformations will
be very large.
In fact, this node here will
go across all the way up to
here, and that node
we go across all
the way down to here.
The displacement of the top
hinge of the frame is shown on
this view graph.
Notice here we are plotting the
load p vertically up, and
the displacement of the top
hinge horizontally.
Notice as the displacements are
very large, you're going
up to almost 25 inches here.
Notice that for this solution,
we used a load increment of
250 pounds.
So we used 80 steps to come from
zero to 20,000 pounds.
Notice this, of course, is a
very large number of steps.
You would have used another
80 steps here and so on.
We wanted to use a small load
incrementation because we
wanted to obtain many solution
points along this curve to be
able to produce an animation
of the frame response.
And I'd like to now share
with you this animation.
We'd like to look at
the animation.
And I'd like to really look
at the animation twice.
First we will look at the
animation of the frame
response in very large
deformations, very fast.
And then we want to look at the
same animation, but in a
slower movement, so that
I can also talk a
little bit about it.
Because the fast version is
going so fast that I can't
really say very much.
So let's now look at
this animation.
Here we see the frame
is discretized
by the isobeam elements.
The two thick arrows show
the load application.
Here you see how the frame go
through the last deformations.
Let's now look at the same
animation again with a
somewhat longer time scale.
We perform, of course,
a static analysis.
The time code above the
picture of the frame
gives the load step.
You also see the load applied
for each step.
Here you see once again how
the frame deforms when
subjected to the loads.
Certainly the frame undergoes
very large displacements, and
for the higher load levels the
analysis represents only a
numerical experiment.
But surely an interesting one.
This completes our discussion of
the frame analysis example,
and I would like now to look
with you at the last example
in this lecture, namely the
analysis of the failure and
repair of a beam cable
structure.
For this analysis, we use one
option in the ADINA program
that is quite valuable, namely
is the option of element birth
and element death.
What this means is that we can
assign certain elements that
are born in the analysis as
this step by step solution
proceeds, and we can assign to
certain element, so to say,
their deaths.
They are disappearing at
a particular time.
This kind of analysis option
is very useful to simulate,
for example, construction
processes and repairs of
structures.
As well known, structures can,
of course, collapse during the
repair, or even during their
construction sequence.
And therefore it can be
important to actually simulate
this sequence of construction,
or the repair of the office
structure, also on the computer,
to find out the
particular construction sequence
or repair of a
structure that one wants
to proceed with.
Here we have a simple cable
beam structure.
This is a cantilever beam
subjected to gravity loading,
and here the cable is hinged at
this end of the beam and up
there so as to support
the beam.
Notice the material data for the
cable are given here, and
there's no pretension
in the cable.
The beam itself has these
material data.
So we model the elasto-plastic
response of the beam.
Here is the mass density
of to beam.
The cross section is
shown over here.
In this analysis, we simulate
the failure and repair of the
cable in the following way.
In load step one, the beams sags
under its weight, but is
supported by the cable.
From load step one to
two the cable snaps.
In other words, for example,
if delta t is equal to 1.
The time step delta t that we
talked about in the earlier
lectures is equal to 1, then
at 1 this would be the load
condition, and at time 1.5, the
cable would snap, so that
at time 2 at the end of the
second load step, the cable is
not anymore in the finite
element system, and
the beam now sags.
It undergoes plastic flow
at the built-in end.
Now, in the next steps, two
to four, the new cable is
installed and is tensioned
until the tip of the beam
returns to its original
location, namely the location
that it had taken at the
end of load step one.
This is quite easily simulated
with this element birth and
death option available in the
computer program you're using.
Notice one element dies, namely
the cable element dies
at time 1.5, say, and then at
2.5 the cable is again there,
and at time 3 and at time
4 we see that the
cable has been tensioned.
Here's the finite
element model.
We used two truss elements
here to model the cable.
And we used five 2-node
Hermitian beam elements to
model the beam.
Notice for the beam element,
we use five Newton-Cotes
integration points in the r
direction, three Newton-Cotes
integration points in
the s direction.
In load step one, the active
truss is number one.
It's there.
At the end of load step two,
no truss element is there,
because remember, between load
step one and load step two, at
time 1.5, if delta t is equal to
1, this one cable, this one
truss element disappears.
It dies, so to say.
And then there is no more truss
connecting this point to
that point at the end
of load step two.
At time two.
Now, in the next load step a
new truss element is born.
Truss number two.
It might be born, for example,
at a specific time 2.5, if
delta t is equal to 1.
And now the truss
is in position.
It has been born.
And we are tensioning it
from load step three
to load step four.
In the solution we use the UL
formulation for the truss
elements and the
beam elements.
The convergence tolerances
are listed here.
Notice that because we have
rotational degrees of freedom
for the beam, we also use a
tolerance RMNORM the way I
describe it in the earlier
lecture when we talked about
convergence tolerances.
Let us now look at the
solution algorithm
performances.
If we use a full Newton method
with line searches all load
steps are successfully
calculated.
The normalized solution
time, say, is one.
The full Newton method without
line searches did not work.
We could not use
the full Newton
method for this problem.
The BFGS method in this
particular case worked quite
nicely, but it needed
more time.
Two and a half times the amount
of time that the full
Newton method required
with line searches.
Of course, the BFGS method
always has line searches.
And if you use the modified
Newton method, with or without
line searches, we did not
converge in load step two.
So, this shows that really the
full Newton method with line
searches is very powerful, and
in this particular case it is
even the cheapest.
The BFGS method did also
quite well, but is
quite a bit more expensive.
The results in all of
this analysis are
listed in this table.
Load step one, the displacement
at the tip of the
cantilever is shown here.
The stress in the cable.
And the moment at the
built-in end.
Load step two, this is
the tip displacement.
Please see the very large
increment in the tip
displacement, because
the cable is gone.
There is no more cable.
And the moment at the built-in
end has also increased a lot.
Now we have installed the repair
cable, so to say, and
in load step three we have
reduced the tip displacement
from 0.63 0.31 meters.
The stress in the cable
is given here.
And the moment at the built-in
end is given here.
And in the final load step,
we've tightened the cable
enough to get back to the
displacement that the
cantilever had at its
tip originally.
Same numbers here.
And the stress in the
cable is given here.
And the moment at the
built-in end of the
cantilever is given here.
The last view graph here shows
the deformations of the
structure pictorially.
Here you see the deformations
at load step one--
here the beam, here the cable.
Notice that these displacements
are magnified by
a factor of 10.
These are the deformations
of the beam at the end
of load step two.
Notice there is no cable here,
and also these deformations
have not been magnified.
Very large deformations.
Load step three, at the end of
load step three, we see the
cable here, the new cable
that has been installed.
And we see also that the tip
displacement of the cantilever
has been reduced by tightening
that new cable already up.
Now, at the end of load step
four, the displacement at the
tip of the cantilever are the
same displacement as we have
measured at the end
of load step one.
Here again we have magnified
the displacements
by a factor of 10.
This then brings us to the
end of this example.
I wanted to show you this
example really as a
demonstrative example to
indicate to you how this
element birth and death option
can be used quite effectively
to simulate repairs
of structures.
In actual analysis you, of
course, might want to use a
finer finite element
discretization and also a
finer integration scheme to
pick up the spread of
plasticity more accurately.
However, this example as a
demonstrative example really
shows to us how we can use this
element birth and death
option to simulate such
processes as repairs of
structures.
And I think you can easily
visualize how this element
birth and death option can
also be used to simulate
construction sequences
of structures.
This then brings me to the
end of this lecture.
Thank you very much for
your attention.